I just finished playing three hours of
Mirror's Edge catalyst and it makes me
feel a lot of things it makes me feel
nostalgic it makes me feel anticipation
but most of all it makes me want to go
fast
Mears edge is all about movement running
dodging jumping sliding through thin
corridors and wide open rooftops you're
not just getting to your destination
you're improvising your direction and
movements to the world around you you're
often pushed to get there and a certain
amount of time but it's not always about
speed there's an entirely different way
to travel and it's in style Mirror's
Edge focuses on one particular aspect of
gameplay player locomotion for games
about movements fluid gameplay and tight
controls at a key components to a
player's sense of control and immersion
they fill in the illusion that we have
stake in the experience at hand that we
can control the outcome and as such it
makes or breaks our connection to the
game the feeling you get from
stylistically moving from platform to
platform or gracefully dodging enemies
in succession is uniquely satisfying and
it deserves a bit more explanation what
causes us to believe that it game feels
just right but the player and the
character are one in tow you've probably
thought to yourself after you finished a
perfectly time move that you got a good
momentum going well there's a strong
association with momentum in games that
focus on player locomotion some of this
is muscle memory or motor learning which
is a form of procedural memory where you
assign a specific motor task into a
memory through repetition hence if
you're stuck on a platform in Super Meat
Boy and that requires a specific pattern
of button presses at very specific times
they'll eventually program your fingers
to execute precise button presses that
result in you inching your way to the
finish line when you get everything just
right you become aware of how much
momentum who's actually built up in your
runs games with combat like Batman
Arkham Asylum will repeat particular
patterns encouraging you to learn
specific maneuvers like evade or ground
takedown then allow you to link these
patterns together in various ways to
make the battle your own in both of
these examples players seize obstacles
as visual puzzles and develops a rhythm
so they can navigate with patience and
precision
but games about fluid locomotion are
more than just the player they're about
environmental awareness and interaction
where the world in which the game takes
place is more than just a backdrop maps
where you're encouraged to explore and
experiment or discovery is part of the
fun design of the world should encourage
you to travel to the same place in
various ways like when you get the light
seeds in Prince of Persia or look for
shortcuts when you need to find all the
tapes and letters and Tony Hawk's Pro
Skater sometimes it's just exploring and
experimenting to have a better
understanding of the map than your
opponent's excellent level design
encourages the player that there's more
than just the fastest way or the safest
way or the funnest way the important
thing is there's not really a best way
just a way that fits your particular
motivations or your style
an important aspect of fluid locomotion
is control I spent time in game learning
how to play and I'm rewarded with skills
not my character skills my skills there
are a lot of games where you got to
spend points to unlock tripped jumps
fast travel giant gun it's like really
Opie but I'm talking about the player
the human you learning skills over time
I could give you the most upgraded car
in dirt rally with all the weight
reduction in the world but you will not
win that race if you can't drive you
have to spend the time in game working
on your movement your accuracy your
reactions in order to get further
simply put you've got to get good
Mirror's Edge catalyst adds a skill tree
for face but you still have to practice
the skills it still takes precision to
roll at the end of a jump getting better
at a game through sheer skill feels
infinitely better than just upgrading
your character the gamers rewarding you
for your hard work not the amount of
time that he played the original
Mirror's Edge honed in on these key
aspects of control control the character
control of the environment and control
of the player's individual skill some
eight years later we're getting a sequel
Mirror's Edge catalyst makes a lot of
changes to the original game now there's
an open map that allows you to choose
between story and side missions and time
trials and faith has those upgrades via
the skill tree these mechanics seem to
be inspired by more recent open world
games ironically a games that might have
been inspired by the original Mirror's
Edge in the first place so here we are
full circle a game that focused on fluid
controls makes an impact on the games
industry and then in turn adapts its own
gameplay for a more open and interactive
experience but the core of the original
game is still there at the end of the
day you're just focusing on your
movement your momentum
nimbly maneuvering precarious
environments with adept leaps over
rooftops taking routes for speed or
style or simply to feel the rush so I'm
really looking forward to Mirror's Edge
catalyst we'll have to wait until the
game comes out to see if it makes you
feel like you're flying or just falling
with style